In this video, we're going to show you how you can configure Burp Suite Enterprise Edition to
integrate with Okta so that you can use SAMR-based SSL. Now before you get started, there's a couple
of prerequisites which need to be in place. First of all, under Network Settings and Burp, you'll
need to make sure that your server URL includes both the protocol and port information. If you
need help doing this, you can look at our documentation pages. Next, within Okta, you'll need to make
sure that you've configured your users correctly. Once you've done this, you can get started
with the integration. First, we'll go to the cog icon here, click Integrations, scroll down
to SAML and click Configure. We'll need these three URLs later on in the process. Next, we're
going to go to the Okta dashboard and sign in as an administrator. Once we're there, we're
going to expand Applications and then click Applications within there. Then we'll click
Create App Integration and choose SAML 2.0 and click Next. We'll then need to give the application
a name. I'm just going to call this Burp Enterprise Documentation Demo, but you can name it whatever
you like. We'll then need to provide some SAML properties, which Okta will provide during the
SAML handshake. The first one is Single Sign-On URL. For this, we're going to use the Relying
Party Service URL from within Burp Enterprise. I'll just copy this link here and then paste
it into here. We'll then make Recipient URL and Destination URL checkbox is ticked. For
Audience URI, we're going to use the Relying Party Trust Identifier, again from the Enterprise
Console. I'll then paste that into here. We'll then need to add a Group Attribute Statement.
The name for that is going to be http colon slash slash schemas dot xml soap dot org forward
slash claims forward slash group. The name format can stay as unspecified and then the filter
needs to be matches regex with the value of dot star. We can then click Next. At this step,
we can click I'm a software vendor and then click Finish. Once the application has been created,
we'll need to get some information from the application which Okta provides us in order to
finish the integration in Burp Enterprise. To get this, under the application which you've
just made, go to Sign On, Sign On Methods and go down to the SAML 2.0 section. Then expand
the More Details block. We'll need the Sign On URL, the Issuer and the Sign On Certificate.
So back into Burp Enterprise, we need to provide the Identity Provider Entity ID. This is the
Sign On URL. For the Certificate, you'll need to download the Sign Certificate and then open
that in a text editor. I'm going to copy the certificate from here and then paste it into
this block here. And then I'm going to add a company name into the Company Details section.
This is what we'll show in Enterprise when you go to log in. On the login page, I'm going
to call it a Portswigger, but you can give it a company name for where you work or anything
that you'd like to show as a descriptive block during the sign-in page. And then I'm going
to click Save. Once I've got the tick, I know that the integration has succeeded. To show
that it works, I'll sign out of her. And I'll sign out of Okta as well, so I don't get any
conflicting users. I can now see the sign-in with Portswigger block, which we now have because
we configured it to be like that within the SAML integration page in Enterprise. So I can
now click Login. I'll get redirected to Okta and then I'll sign in as my user. And you can
see that I've been signed in to Burp. And that is how you configure Burp Suite Enterprise
Edition to work with Okta for SAML-based SSL.